I do have a voicemail number that you
can call any time of day the numbers
2192 david p let's take a listen to a
voicemail that came in yesterday well
apparently in our rural hard right
country you have to approve of Russia in
order to be a patriot um that looks like
words going I'm really scared too I
don't know yet I'm not sure if that is
taking it a little too far in terms of
you have to approve of Russia to be a
patriot but it is stunning how in four
years we went from Mitt Romney the
Republican candidate for president says
Russia and Putin are our biggest geo
political foes and Republicans by and
large agreeing with that to Russia
hacked our election according to the CIA
and FBI Trump praises Putin Putin
praises Trump Rex Tillerson the incoming
Secretary of State major friend of Putin
and of Russia business deals etcetera
and now Republicans saying maybe it's
good to be friendly with Russia Russia
may not actually be that bad it is
stunning the reversal that we have seen
on the bonus show today a new study
confirms what many of us suspected
lurking on facebook makes people
miserable John Kasich has expanded
concealed carry in daycares and colleges
in Ohio and the potential aerosol that
might cool the earth very very
interesting stories on today's bonus
show of course you can access the bonus
show instantly by becoming a david
pakman show member at david pakman.com
slash membership if prices are too high
use coupon code i voted 17 and please
please please check out our crowdfunding
campaign at david pakman.com slash
donate even if you can only donate a
couple bucks please do i really
appreciate the 250 plus donors that have
already contributed